we can debate whether it makes sense but
Michael Bloomberg is now pretty damn
solidly in third place nationally in the
2020 Democratic primary Michael
Bloomberg has pulled ahead of now fourth
place Elizabeth Warren certainly ahead
of now fifth place Pete Budaj edge and
if Joe Biden continues his downward
trajectory dropping like a lead balloon
over the last 10 days and Michael
Bloomberg keeps gaining at the rate that
he has been Bloomberg could conceivably
be in second place nationally before
Super Tuesday I don't totally understand
what's going on but I want to go through
the data with you and see if we can
figure out what is going on here let's
check out the latest polling as you can
see Michael Bloomberg if you're watching
along with me polling 15 16 and 17
in three of the last five national polls
no lower than 11 in any of those when we
look at his trajectory on your screen
you will see the red arrow pointing to
the orange line which is Michael
Bloomberg entering the race at 2.5% in
mid-november climbing to where he is now
in third place with an average of 14
point 2 percent in recent polling
nationally and then when you look at
Biden's trajectory there you see this
just drastic decline if the trend
continues Bloomberg could again pass
Biden within about 10 days looking now
at the exact numbers by candidate you
will see that Joe Biden is just five
points ahead of Michael Bloomberg 19.22
fourteen point two if Biden loses two
and a half points and Bloomberg gains
two and a half if Bloomberg gains three
and Biden loses two any combination that
adds up to five a five-point swing they
will be tied and this will absolutely
shake up the Democratic primary on Super
Tuesday we'll look at some of those
specific state polls in a second now
remember this is all happening after our
friend Benjamin Dixon unearthed some
audio that was available on YouTube but
been found it
subtitled it and
publicized it in which Michael Bloomberg
speaks very insensitive Lee on the issue
of race related to young black men in
the context of stop and frisk millions
and millions and millions of views many
people disgusted by the audio some
people don't care I mean we got calls
this week from viewers who said my
parents like Bloomberg I showed him then
Dixon's audio and they're still gonna
they don't like it but they're still
going to vote for Michael Bloomberg I
don't yet know how the post audio
polling will change for Michael
Bloomberg but if I'm totally honest with
you I don't think it's going to change
that much
sadly my the the the real question that
we're getting to is when does Bloomberg
start winning delegates because remember
polling 5% nationally or 10 or even 14
the way that Michael Bloomberg is doing
now is not particularly useful unless
you can meet the 15% viability threshold
in some individual primaries and start
winning some delegates as you may know
Bloomberg got zero in Iowa New Hampshire
because he skipped them Bloomberg is
skipping Nevada and South Carolina
Bloomberg has already this week been
campaigning in North Carolina an
important Super Tuesday States so when
you look at where we have polling on
Super Tuesday it's looking okay for
Michael Bloomberg there are a bunch of
states that vote on Super Tuesday where
the latest polls are from October like
Bloomberg wasn't even running then we
have no idea what's going on so if you
look at Virginia polling if you look at
Minnesota polling there is no recent
polling out of those states we just
don't know how Michael Bloomberg is
doing California we have quite a bit of
polling and Bloomberg is not doing well
only four percent in California but then
you look at Texas and last month
Bloomberg already was 16 and he may be
higher now you look at Florida Bloomberg
was at 17 in a recent poll you look at
North Carolina where Bloomberg has been
spending some time this week at 15% so
that is a fair number of Delegates and
this is both disgusting because he's
just buying his way in I mean this is
this is the height of or
the bottom of the barrel of depending on
how you want to think about it this is
the height of the of the Oleg our key of
the kleptocracy and we're gonna you talk
about that word in the context of
Bloomberg a little bit later on today
it's also fascinating though because the
combination of a bunch of establishment
centrists splitting some of the of the
delegates so far biden Budaj edge and
clover char on the other hand because
there's a big division between the
candidates you have Bernie Sanders doing
very well winning the popular vote in
both Iowa and New Hampshire and yet not
currently leading in delegates it's
fascinating that Michael Bloomberg may
soon get himself not just the second
place in the popular vote nationally he
may end up actually getting more
delegates than a number of the other
primary or sort of a more likely
candidates last thing and I want to talk
about I wanted to vote a little bit of
time to this because it is so weird
there is some reason that must explain
why Michael Bloomberg so easily and so
thoroughly triggers Donald Trump and
that's what I want to talk about next do
you feel like you just don't have enough
time to become as intellectually
well-rounded as you would like to be
that they're just not enough hours in
your week for you to read all of the
books that you want to read one of our
sponsors is called blinka stand it's an
app that lets you consume an entire
nonfiction book in 15 minutes it's only
about 8 bucks a month but you can try it
for free for a week and get 25% off a
subscription
when you go to blankest comm slash
Pakman what blinka studs is take
thousands of popular non-fiction books
and condense them into either text or
audio that you can read or listen to in
just 15 minutes and what you get is all
of the most important ideas and
information from the book imagine being
able to listen to an entire non-fiction
book in the amount of time it takes you
to drive or walk home from work I just
finished listening to the way we eat now
by bee Wilson whose work I've
recommended to you before super
interesting look at how the global food
system work
and impacts the way that we live
blinkie's has totally transformed how I
consume information I love it of course
I read a book in its entirety when I can
but there are simply just so many books
that I want to read and would not have
the time for if it weren't for bling
cast they have books on politics
economics philosophy science you name it
you can try it out yourself totally free
for a week and get 25% off if you decide
to subscribe just by going to blink is
comm slash Pakman I've put the link
right underneath this video like the
rest of us I bet you're going into 2020
thinking about what you didn't get
around to in 2019 and your goals for the
new year if you want to work towards
being your best self in 2020 understand
more about the world around you and make
sure that your time is well spent then
blink astiz for you